To answer your question,
the dog is real
What is up, all you beautiful people!
It's Ashley here
And today's little video is based on an article called,
Reading Fiction Improves Empathy
Have you ever finished a book
and then felt like a better person?
and then felt like a more understanding person?
Has a book ever made you cry?
Now reading is a great hobby of mine,
and every single time I finish any kind of fiction book
I always feel like I gained a new perspective on life
And that's because studies have shown
that reading fiction improves empathy
What exactly is empathy?
"The ability to understand someone's feelings and problems."
So studies were conducted to explore this
1,000 people were split up into four groups
And these groups were
Popular fiction,
Literary fiction,
Nonfiction,
And no reading assignment
They read excerpts
Pertaining to their groups
And after that took a test
And the test was to measure their ability
To understand people's thoughtsand emotions
And the results are in!
Those who were assigned to read fiction, literary, and popular,
Did a lot more better than
Those who read nonfiction
And had no reading assignment whatsoever
But here's a twist
Between the two types of fiction; literary and popular,
Those who read literary
Did a little bit more better than those who read popular
And why is that?
Well it could be because of the fantastical element
That is present in popular fiction
But you can also find
Some levels of it in literary fiction too
So
Why is it that those who read literary fiction are
More empathetic?
That is definitely something to think about
Comment below letting me know
What kind of fiction books you guys read
And every single time you finish reading one of those books
Do you feel like you're more empathetic?
And that is my time
Thank you so much for watching this video
The link to the article,
"Reading fiction improves empathy"
Is in the description box below.
Hi!
Thought you saw the last of me, didn't you?
I just wanted to remind all of you, beautiful people
That you can find all of our contents on our website
Psych2go.net
Please follow our Tumblr page at
Psych2go.tumblr.com
Please follow us here on our Youtube channel
We'll be posting videos based on the articles
That are available on our website
Please remember to give this video
And all of our videos
A thumbs up to show your love and support
Once again, thank you so much
For watching this video
And I'll see you next time!